bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
entretien de france 24 avec nous
aujourd'hui la porte-parole du ministère
de l'europe et des affaires étrangères a
une claire legendre bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation de
france 24 alors c'est une période
diplomatiquement trouble et c'est un
euphémisme
une période qui est dominée largement
par l'invasion militaire russe en
ukraine la diplomatie est soumise à rude
épreuve et on assiste un peu de manière
contrainte à une forme de redéfinition
d'une certaine idée des relations
internationales donc voilà on va en
parler évidemment ensemble sur soi
france 24 je voudrais commencer si vous
permettez par le sahel par le mali les
relations entre bamako et paris qui sont
quasi au point mort la force barca
d'acquitter le mali le 15 août dernier
est-ce que les ressortissants français à
bamako peuvent craindre d'être évacuée
ce qu'on en est là dans les relations
écoutez nous avons fait ce retrait de
barkan du mali dans le calendrier qui
avait été imposé dans le bon ordre comme
l'a souligné le président de la
république lors de la conférence des
ambassadeurs il a salué d'ailleurs nos
forces armées pour la bonne réalisation
de cette de cette opération nos
ressortissants évidemment nous avons une
très forte vigilance pour leur sécurité
notre ambassade est à leurs côtés
regarde la situation sur le terrain et à
ce stade nous n'avons pas changé nos
conseils aux voyageurs la ministre
catherine colonna at fait d'une sortie
il ya quelques jours qualifiant la jatte
malienne qui naviguait je la cite
d'échec en échec c'est pas trés
conciliatoire comme comme ton nous avons
constaté et c'est la raison du retrait
même de barkan que les conditions
politiques et les conditions de sécurité
n'étaient plus réunies pour pouvoir
maintenir notre présence sur le
territoire ce n'était plus le soin non
plus des autorités maliennes donc nous
sommes aujourd'hui nous avons pris acte
de cette situation et
nous avançons nous avançons parce que
nous discutons avec les états du sahel
mais aussi avec les états du golfe de
guinée sur la manière de ré articuler ce
dispositif nous souhaitons le faire sous
une nouvelle forme vous savez que la
ministre était au niger avec le ministre
des armées en juillet le président
évidemment à effectuer cette tournée au
bénin au cameroun en guinée-bissau pour
aussi évoqué ces sujets et l'idée c'est
de le faire en appui des états qui le
souhaiteraient donc qui en ferait la
demande beaucoup plus intégrée avec les
forces armées locales et évidemment en
réponse à la menace terroriste
malheureusement nous voyons grossir ou
le on vous le mentionnez parfaitement on
a eu ce discours de cotonou du président
macron résolument beaucoup plus offensif
il cale dernièrement pour la conférence
des ambassadeurs il a en juin et
exhorter le corps diplomatique à plus de
d'agressivité je le paraphrase un peu de
mémoire est ce que c'est une lutte pour
l'influencé française que c'est pas un
peu trop tard et ce qu'on n'intervient
pas un peu trop tard sur ces domaines
alors il ya le discours de cotonou mais
il ya eu le discours de ouagadougou en
2017 et le président avait des wag a du
goût tracer les lignes d'un nouveau
partenariat avec l'afrique donc depuis
2010 est on a vu se mettre en place les
différents éléments de ce nouveau
partenariat le premier c'était aussi
regarder notre histoire en face et on
voit bien que cet effort il se poursuit
il ya eu l'ouverture des archives sur le
rwanda il ya cet effort mené sur
l'algérie il y a également maintenant la
décision prise d'ouvrir une commission
d'historiens avec le cameroun et puis
cela porte aussi sur des éléments qui
suscitait des réticences comme par
exemple le franc cfa où vous savez que
la france depuis 2018 ne fait plus
partie des instances de gouvernance
monétaire donc tous ces éléments là
c'était arrivé à regarder notre histoire
en face aussi trouver les moyens de
dépasser cette histoire et ensuite de
construire les nouvelles bases d'un
partenariat à la fois avec les étangs et
c'est ce que nous avons fait avec le
sommet ua qui a permis de définir
finalement un nouvel agenda y compris
sur des enjeux globaux qui sont
essentiels pour l'afrique comme la santé
la crise alimentaire les infrastructures
avec 150 milliards d'euros qui vont être
investis par l'union européenne dans les
infrastructures et puis enfin troisième
pilier et ça c'est vraiment ce sur quoi
le président nous a incités nous les
diplomates à travailler plus activement
c'est ouvrir avec la société civile avec
les entrepreneurs les jeunes les
artistes un nouveau dialogue qui
permette de créer beaucoup plus de lien
entre les deux pays et ça c'est concret
il y as to africa va y avoir création
africa une maison des mondes africains
tous ces éléments là ils sont déjà en
place et ils vont continuer à être mises
en oeuvre cette année anne claire
legendre les éléments narratifs turcs
russes ou chinois qui a dénoncé le
président de la république et puis
appelant à cette diplomatie de combat on
pourrait résumer ainsi on sent qu'on a
pas les mêmes armes non plus quand on
voit la propagande russe qui se
développe au sahel sera free que ben ali
burkina faso qui va extrêmement vite ce
ne sont pas nécessairement les mêmes
armes et encore moins les mêmes moyens
et c'est en ma question est est-ce qu'on
peut inverser danser dans ces conditions
cette propagande anti française qui
qu'on le veuille ou non se propage alors
nous sommes d'une démocratie donc nous
n'allons pas faire de la propagande et
le président de la république l'a très
clairement souligné mais il nous a
appelés comme vous le soulignez à une
diplomatie de combat et la ministre nous
a invités et a invité tous ses
ambassadeurs est beaucoup plus présent
dans l'espace virtuel faire en sorte de
contrecarrer ces narrative puisque ce
qu'il importe tout d'abord c'est de
casser des éléments qui sont totalement
sans fondement et qui sont
malheureusement relayé à la fois par des
acteurs étatiques mais aussi par des
acteurs non étatiques en afrique et
ailleurs
donc nous allons pour ce pour ce faire
créer réarmer notre diplomatie c'est ce
que la ministre a indiqué avec des
nouveaux crédits des nouveaux emplois
qui seront créés au quai d'orsay
notamment sur ces questions de lutte
contre la désinformation est ce qu'on
est entré vraiment en guerre
informationnelle c'est un élément de
langage qu'on entend beaucoup en ce
moment alors le président a très
clairement dit guère hybride mondialisé
de la part de la russie et c'est ce
qu'on voit se déployer sur les réelles
sur les réseaux sociaux en afrique mais
sur d'autres terrains et notamment sur
la guerre en ukraine où vous êtes des
informations fait feu de tout bois à la
fois vis-à-vis de ce qui se passe en
ukraine mais aussi en russie où la
population russe est maintenu dans une
bulle de propagande la capacité d
influence de la france sur les anciens
pays où on avait deux influences est-ce
qu'on peut revenir dessus concrètement
je crois que les adapte le mot nenê
n'est plus le bon on parle de
partenariat est donc ce que nous
apportons est-ce que n'apporte pas ses
autres compétiteurs puisque il faut
rappeler les chiffres 1 l'aide russe en
afrique elle elle est complètement
venir minime au regard de ce que
apporter l'union européenne qui reste le
premier contributeur le corby soutenir
les russes pourquoi on entend tellement
les russes par exemple parce qu'ils
utilisent des moyens ils se disent des
fermes à troll il monétise finalement
toute une partie de la désinformation il
réutilise aussi ce qu'est ce qui a pu
fait vraiment être une grande école de
la propagande qu'on connaissait pendant
pendant la pendre la guerre froide donc
c'est une à une vieille industrie russe
qui a trouvé de nouveaux moyens sur les
réseaux sociaux vous avez parlé en
interrogeant de la guerre froide est ce
que vous tenez dans un paradigme qui
s'apparenterait avec évidemment toutes
les conditions de cette mondialisation
de l'information dans une nouvelle
guerre froide avec la guerre d'ukraine
qui a peut-être changé beaucoup de
choses ce qu'a souligné le président
c'est le risque de fracturation de
l'ordre international et il nous a
demandé de lutter contre ça donc nous ne
voulons pas entrer dans une logique de
bloc c'est ce que souhaite la des
meilleures poutines sans doute qui
veut revenir à cette logique d'empyr et
veut revenir finalement / / / la chute
de l'union soviétique
ce n'est pas notre soi et la ministre
nous a appelés à être plus actifs pour
construire des nouveaux partenariats et
donc l'afrique évidemment éteindre ces
nouveaux partenariats sur lesquels nous
travaillons depuis le discours de 2017
mais on mentionne aussi l'inde au
pacifique avec lesquels nous travaillons
beaucoup et il y aura beaucoup de
déplacements dans cette région dans
l'est dans les semaines et mois à venir
et notamment à l'occasion du g20 qui est
présidée par alain donné et je vous
remercie pour cette transition parfaite
on va parler de la des relations entre
chez la chiné et taiwan dents de scie
pelosi plus haut dignitaire américain no
25 ans à avoir fait le déplacement des
buts début août a créé à taïwan a créé
l'ire de pékin on s'est un peu
prévisibles résultat il ya eu des
manoeuvres militaires les plus
importantes presque inédite qui sont
approchés très très dangereusement deux
de taïwan qui t'a beaucoup inquiété les
23 millions de taiwanais il ya dans
quelques heures une mission
parlementaire menée par des sénateurs
français qui va atterrir à taïwan est ce
qu'on va avoir la même réaction de pékin
alors vous êtes familier de la
séparation du législatif de l'exécutif
donc il ne me revient pas de commenter
deux parlementaires parce que c'est un
cas s'est déroulée à taïwan nous notre
sujet sur taïwan et encore une fois ces
visites ne sont pas sans précédent notre
sujet sur la question c'est de maintien
du statu quo est de faire en sorte
d'éviter les risques d'escaladé
lorsqu'on a pu voir c'est elle en effet
des manoeuvres qui avait pu créer des
risques escale à thouars dans la région
et les messages que nous avons fait
passer à la fois à titre national mais
également par le biais du g7 avec lequel
nous sommes s'exprimer collectivement
c'était d'appeler à une désescalade de
la situation et au maintien de ce statu
quo que nous souhaitons voir préserver
dans la région mais quand l'ambassadeur
de l'ue représentant taiwanais en france
sur notre antenne avant de partir
justement pour accueillir les sénateurs
français appellent à plus de soutien de
la part de l'europe de la france quelle
réponse nous n'avons pas de relations
diplomatiques avec taïwan comme vous
savez mais nous avons des relations
extrêmement étroites donc que ce soit au
plan commercial culturel de coopération
et nous savons aussi que les vannes 3
millions de taiwanais partage avec nous
beaucoup de choses des valeurs donc
c'est cette relation elle est là et elle
va co evans poursuivants et pour parler
de relation vos homologues chinois est
ce qu on appelle cette génération de
loups combattants qui ont une quand même
une politique une doctrine assez
conquérante qui est d'ailleurs bien
représentée par votre homologue
chinois à paris monsieur lellouche
acquis qui fait des sorties quand même
assez assez fréquentes est-ce qu'on a
encore une fois les mêmes armes pour
combattre avec une telle agressivité
tout ça dans le champ diplomatique ne
nous souhaitons garder aussi une voie de
la diplomatie notre objectif n'est pas
de tenir des propos escale at war
quand le président appelle à une plume
acide combat il souhaite que nous
puissions rétablir les faits et faire en
sorte que
que cette désinformation aller contre à
l'encontre d'un autre pays mais aussi à
l'encontre de grands principes du droit
international qui sont aujourd'hui
bafouées par la part la russie ne soit
pas mise en cause de cette manière là et
très rapidement vous craignez que le que
taiwan ne soit envahi par par là par la
chine là qu'en 2025 2026 comme le disent
les les experts écoutez la question
hypothétique nous notre position à
l'éclair on l'a réaffirmé et encore une
fois nous travaillons aussi dans le
cadre de cette stratégie indo pacifique
à faire en sorte que la souveraineté des
états dans cette région puisse être
préservé anne claire legendre porte
parole du ministère de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères je vous remercie
c'est la fin de cet entretien de france
24 les programmes continus sur nos
antennes en français en anglais en arabe
et en espagnol merci
[Musique]
parlons semble chaque jour toutes les
idées s'exprime sur france 24
analyse chaque spécificité débat
les
entretiens avec les personnalités qui
font l'actualité politique et économique
en france et dans le monde
france24 leur donne la parole
parlons-en sur france 24 et france 24
points comme